foreign
can I just share a tiny bit about hotels
uh sure yeah I mean he's pretty great
the amazing hotels the amazing Peter
Hotes uh nature this week vaccine
specialist Peter Hotes scientists are
under attack for someone else's
political gain
you don't say
I don't think he's talking about us no
um you know the funny thing is
um he's right he's right scientists are
under attack for someone else's
political gain Peter hotes's political
gain and he's the one doing the
attacking in many cases yeah yeah it's a
it's an amazing thing to say yeah the
physician researcher who spoke out
against misinformation during the
covid-19 pandemic says attacks against
science are formidable and getting worse
yeah we noticed
okay so I mean this is ridiculous this
whole thing's ridiculous it's a book
review because how Dez has a book out oh
yeah um and
um it's a deadly rise of anti-science a
scientists warning
um published by Johns Hopkins University
press Johns Hopkins has been terrific
during all of this as well I just want
to scan to the bottom of this ridiculous
thing and um share the last paragraph
how can this be stopped what's your
advice for dealing with online trolls
have you changed anyone's mind
in your book's dedication you thank
police departments and hospital security
forces for keeping your family safe how
do you deal with fear
the end of that answer he says they with
regard to the right-wing media stoking
fear and outrage no stoking the faux
outrage machine
and monetizing the internet they
couldn't care less about me it's what I
represent he says ooh shades of fouches
shades of vouchers shades of faucy okay
so what's your message to scientists
nature asks hotels in its final adoring
uh question to him
understand hota says that Science And
scientists are under threat and it's a
coordinated campaign what you're doing
as a scientist is Noble scientists
should feel good about what they do by
reading my book you shouldn't be
demoralized understand that it's not you
who's doing something wrong you're under
attack for someone else's political gain
even though it's scary I think there's
some comfort in that
yeah that takes something from a guy
who's still pushing mRNA vaccines for
kids yeah the ball's on this guy yeah
um amazing tiny but a very effective
apparently yeah I guess in this case
maybe the gall is a better like imagine
imagine him covered in Galls or
something
yeah
I will hold my tongue about all the
things that one might say connecting
Galls for those of you playing along at
home are the swellings on Plants induced
by insects we then lay their eggs inside
these um they're not attractive and the
plants presumably don't like them
they're not good for the plants no it's
not good for the plants yeah pretty cool
though I always uh very interesting
always always I'm intrigued when I
encounter them yeah Ralph Barrick uh at
uh Chapel Hill is the
um
primary architect of the set of
techniques uh in gain of function
research used to Turbo Charge and
enhance a specially
coronaviruses in other words though we
think much of the work that resulted in
coronavirus happened in Wuhan the
precursor work that uh created the
insight into how to modify
viruses to take them from a state in
which they were not an effective human
pathogen into a highly effective human
pathogen came from the Barrick lab he
famously innovated
what he called no see him techniques
which meant that Not only was he able to
make modifications that made these
things into deadly pathogens
um but he was able to do so in a way
that was invisible to those who might
look in and see whether some
modification had been made
and uh the kind of research that he was
doing that he was doing primarily in the
U.S
uh I got a cease and desist order placed
on it under the Obama Administration and
then
fauci's niaid helped move much of that
research offshore to the Wuhan Institute
of virology yeah so I sort of think of
Barrack as the guy who made all this
possible and fauchi is the guy who made
it all happen
all right
um anyway Barrick has been
um
quite quiet when he pipes up it is
because something important is afoot and
so Zach if you would show
um the Barrack paper what happens here
is that Barrick attempts to revive the
hypothesis that many will remember from
the very early parts of the pandemic
that the intermediate host between
horseshoe bats and humans for SARS cov2
was pangolins now this work is long
discredited there were coronaviruses
found in pangolins these were pangolins
that were being smuggled there's no
ecological explanation for why pangolins
would be harboring these bat viruses
there are many many reasons to Discount
this explanation but what Barrick
attempts to do here
is create an unfalsifiable explanation
of how this virus came to humans and
left no Trace
now as as our viewers will remember me
talking about can I just read what I'm
seeing here like this is brand new to me
um pangolins which harbor distinct Stars
Kobe 2 related strains are an endangered
solitary species but are valuable as
illegal trade commodities
on the basis of broad ace2 receptor
usage of pgcovgd documented Airborne
transmission potential and efficient
growth in primary nasal Airway Airway
epithelial cells we suggest that
individual pangolins or perhaps some
other rare Wildlife species was
productively infected and served as a
nearly untraceable pass-through species
that transmitted Virus to humans
[Music]
is he serious here yes and then he says
such rare events might be enhanced if
early human cases were immunosuppressed
potentially generating complex
mutational variants during persistent
infections so make no mistake what's
going on here
Barrack is creating a theoretically
possible pathway that would leave no
evidence if you started with the if you
said
Dr Barrick
the virus did not come from a lab
what is your best explanation of how it
might have gotten to us without leaving
any evidence of an intermediate host in
which it circulated or evidence in early
human populations where rapid Evolution
took place because it was poorly adapted
when it first made its way into people
if you said come up with your best
your best scenario that will accomplish
these things you would come up with
something like this doesn't make it
plausible but the point is what he is
hypothesizing here I think best could be
better than this nope you don't think so
you're not understanding the assignment
okay yeah I don't the assignment is
exonerate the lab with an unfalsifiable
hypothesis that could have happened oh
you know I mean like scientifically best
most plots this is scientific garbage
right you know this is unfalsified it's
like put a side lab as a possibility now
what's the most supported hypothesis out
there so the base the basic
um reality
is that jumping between species is much
much harder than the people who have
been getting Grant after Grant on the
basis that it was always threatening to
happen have led us to believe and it
leaves a signature because you have to
have these periods of evolution in which
the virus gets better at uh infecting
people and then very importantly jumping
between them it has to do that so what
he's done
is he has cooked up a scenario in which
an immunosuppressed person becomes like
a little gain of function laboratory
unto themselves having gotten the virus
from a Pangolin
and the basic point is that's why we
haven't found any evidence right it's
it's a complete nonsense story designed
to exonerate the lab once again bringing
pangolins back in because as long as
we're now dealing with
unfalsifiable fantasy might as
well be pangolins right might as well be
might as well be this garbage has no
place in nature
it's not nature it's not science yeah
this is
um how do we get this is cover your ass
right this is this is Barrick covering
their asses because what they can't have
he's a they know uh well he and all of
the people who might face a
um you know
criminal prosecution or who knows what
are looking
for a scientific cloak and Barrack uh is
not as good at generating
um seamless when it comes to
narrative as he is creating seamless
when it comes to genomes Merlin
Tuttle extraordinary um that means a
biologist yeah absolutely and just
a photographer and he's responding to
this um Scientific American story called
a secret weapon and preventing the next
pandemic fruit bats
um he says the title appears to promote
a better appreciation of bats however
the next sentence mistakenly claims that
bats worldwide are primary transmitters
of viruses deadly to humans
this flawed conclusion reached a
worldwide audience in 2017 through a
study that reported more viruses and
bats than in other mammals it examined
nearly twice as many bats as all other
animals combined ignoring the fact that
new viruses can be found wherever we
look nevertheless it receives
Sensational media coverage worldwide in
contrast a far more thorough study
concluded that bats did not Harbor more
viruses than other animals but continues
to be mostly ignored as evidenced by the
recent Scientific American article the
scary sensationalist study continues to
dominate public perception of bats
so I thought I'd look at what the
original 2017 study uh was and what the
laters it turns out 2020 study was the
2020 study is by a team of researchers I
don't recognize the 2017 study which is
the piece of evidence that has since
been debunked that is the basis on which
we are blaming bats for things was
published by a team that
includes Peter dessick oh my god oh so
it's perfect it's perfect right perfect
global patterns and chronovirus
diversity publish and virus Evolution
that is the basis on which now
Scientific American and the whole damn
world is blaming bats because they were
really easy culprit right blaming bats
for our own uh arrogance
and so this this is the this is the
perfect
um
uh link with Barrack because Barrick is
here creating fantasy stories completely
unscientific anti-scientific fantasy
stories
about how it is that this terrible virus
got into people when in fact how did it
get into people you Dr Barrick that's
how it got into people you figured out
how to do this and whether you actually
wielded the pipet or it was done in
Wuhan doesn't make any goddamn
difference this was your boilerplate
piece that was posted in all of your
Grant applications and all of the
Publications that came from them
swearing that your work was the thing
that was going to prevent the pandemic
it was the arrogance that allowed you to
believe that that was true that
actually created the pandemic and you
can blame the bats you can blame
pangolins you can blame Frozen ferret
Badgers but the fact is it was you it
was fauci it was dazik it was Anderson
right these people are you know from
nosium edits to cover up these are the
people who make this possible and by
hiding what happened you're making it
certain it's going to happen again
and in the meantime you've unleashed a a
novel virus on the world and uh we'll
never get rid of it which we're stuck
with yeah we're stuck with it
uh and um
it's Unforgivable
honestly well let's put it this way uh
owning up to what you did uh would be a
start and you owe it to us whether or
not it's forgivable
[Music]
thank you